[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to the lobby
game spots weekly hangout where we talk
about the newest video games and the
events of the past week in the video
games industry i'm mike maherty your
host here as usual with pete brown
reviews editor here hey man what have
you been up to have you been reviewing
anything you could talk about uh we're
gonna talk about yakuza later um other
than that not reviewing anything myself
but i am very stoked today i have a very
nerdy purchase can i explain my nerdy
purchase pizza a very avid collector
yeah i mean i don't know where you're
going with this but you're an avid
collector of like old games for people
who don't know yes uh do you know what
the turbo graphics is
no so back
i mean yeah i do but for listeners who
don't explain uh it was basically a
competitor to the superintendent of
genesis kind of back in the day
okay do you understand what it is yeah
okay don't um so the japanese version uh
eventually they released a combined one
that had the cd add-on and the original
system kind of combined in one and i
have one the turbo duo r and it's mine's
a little bit dingy on ebay this weekend
i found a guy in puerto rico selling a
mint like totally extremely clean case
had been modded for rgb video out
already
uh with a cd assembly as well i know
you're following all of this
uh i want it for a dollar 25
and what would you normally expect it to
go for uh you don't see people selling
just the shells of these old consoles
yeah but it makes sense though because
especially one like this that's
extremely clean perfect way to like you
know dress up an old system you've got
that's kind of gross but yeah it's
shipped from puerto rico on monday and
it's showing up today in puerto rico
yeah cool is it like a dry place now is
that where you store these kind of
things i haven't it's in the mail it's
showing up today will it be in a dry
place uh well you put it in water i'm
gonna put it mostly in water
now i'm gonna swap out my old case put
that in the box put that in storage and
then play my system interesting all
right i'm also here with aaron sampson
how's it going mike
going well what uh what are you you're
here to talk about recon today i know i
see a lot of people in the chat we do
have the chat up by the way um again our
audience thanks for joining us we have
the youtube chat the twitch chat open uh
yeah it's right in front of us so feel
free to my head is shaped like a
footpath
thanks udit sing for that comment uh
yeah we are
gonna be monitoring that the entire show
so uh we're glad everybody can hang out
erin what have you been up to lately i
do what i do every weekend which is i
say i'm going to play the call of duty
campaign and then i play titanfall
yeah that sounds right that's pretty
much every weekend we're both good yeah
um what do you think of did you play
titanfall 2's campaign titanfall 2's
campaign was good
like it was
it was
it was it did what it needed to do i
actually was one of the guys who loved
the multiplayer campaign and played a
lot more of the multiplayer campaign
from the first game
and the only thing i wanted was for that
to just be a little bit more involved
for players to actually determine the
outcome of the game because tenfold one
sort of ended with like ah you guys want
some rounds and we won some rounds and
now let's all just fight some more
rounds there was like really no
resolution to no impact the players had
on that did you like the uh i don't
spoil too much but
did you like the effect and cause level
in the campaign did you play that one
the affecting cause level i think it was
rob handler's favorite level uh it was a
lot of people's yeah
it i i thought
that had some stiff competition with and
i don't remember the name but the
factory level
where it was like portal you were
fighting oh yeah you were fighting in a
building
in a building that was being constructed
as you battled on it and like turned
sideways and upside down and i think
it it did incredible things with the the
movement that i hadn't seen before right
yeah um it's kind of a good segue
because there's another mission in um
dishonored two cracking the slab that's
sort of similar mechanics uh and
speaking of designer two to get to our
newsreel section we're just kind of
rattling off smaller events that happen
that we're not devoting entire segments
to designer two's second major update
came out this week um
so apparently it adds a lot of stability
to the pc version so hopefully all those
problems are set um maybe there will be
continuing ones in the future but the
update also adds a mission select option
uh and new difficulty setting sliders on
all three platforms so you can kind of
i don't know affect how fast like sleep
darts take effect which i'm super into
because i play that game really
stealthily um there's also iron mode so
you die you restart the entire game do
you want to play this game with
permadeath just
throwing that out there uh
it would be hard as hell because i then
there's like no i don't think it's like
if it's
x-com two-ish then there's no auto-save
right you just can't
s-that's what the patch notes yeah if
you're dead you're dead that's insane
what's a typical play-through for
dishonored two like how long would you
have to oh man well i
i mean there's nine missions and you can
fly through them if you or you can't you
could fly through them if you want to
i'm on in my replay i'm on mission seven
and i'm at nine hours i'm taking my time
though wow okay yeah so you probably you
could theoretically lose like 14 hours
in this game well yeah if you can
survive that long yeah which is that's
rough oh yeah definitely i imagine you
would have to go a stealth playthrough
um in other news avalanche software who
was a former disney infinity developer
and then they shuttered what two three
months ago
something yeah maybe a couple maybe like
six yeah something like that well
they're back now under warner bros
working on cars three the game aaron you
said it's kind of dark for cars i have
kids in that movie trailer i did not
show my kids that trailer because it was
like really dark
it's just the the empire strikes back of
cars except at the end of the trilogy
like super dark right i don't know like
david fincher is directing cars 3.
that would be a baptism by fire for kids
who have never seen anything besides
cars 1 and 2. uh also overwatch's
chinese new year update was out
yesterday uh so there's new skins
uh new emotes new victory poses and the
aesthetic
arena and also a new 6v6 captures a flag
mode uh but you can score apparently
it's a variant of traditional capture
flag you can score like even if your
flag is not at your base uh the actual
chinese new year year of the rooster
starts saturday but characters like mei
and diva have some pretty sick new
costumes they could have called to
capture the [ __ ] just saying
is
i was waiting for the chat to say it but
no aaron's got us covered
have you been here for the chinese new
year in san francisco or did you go to
the parade last year i did yeah it's
pretty cool um on market street straight
up the city it kind of yeah it cuts
through the tenderloin and then goes
down market yeah but yeah yeah it was it
was a sight for sure it's uh
like those
people had like fireworky looking
fireworks and they had those big dragons
yeah yeah schools like you know learn
how to do that yeah yes uh in a game
that probably won't get as much
attention as say resident evil uh this
week or even yakuza 7 is tales of
berseria is also out yeah as of
yesterday jake decker on our video team
that was his first written review uh he
gave it a 7 out of 10. uh he liked it he
said it's uh
it's a good game for sure as a yeah for
that series it might not advance the
series
in wholly meaningful new ways but it's a
good step in the right direction one of
the things that this game the issue is
that it has to deal with is the fact
that it's a cross-gen title so it's in
japan out on ps3 and ps4 right so the
graphics do suffer a little bit in that
regard and there is some like you know
repetitive elements that kind of like
stick around according to jake but he
also made it sound like really exciting
from a different perspective which is
the series isn't just sort of like light
joyful fantasy like there's some dark
stuff going on people doing mean things
to accomplish their goals because they
just don't care sure um so yeah sounds
pretty good like a sleeper hit yeah he
played a lot
like 50 hours yeah he also played the
preview or he used the review build a
while ago to play a preview for like 15
hours or something
um yeah we are getting to yakuza udit
singh just said yakuza is going to be
lit yup
from everything i've heard i think
that's the case yeah we will get that
we're devoting the entire section um one
more thing that happened today pray
release or pray from arcane studios they
released a new cinematic trailer and
confirmed a release date of may 5th
cinco de mayo how much of this game are
you going to play as a coffee mug as
much as possible that's my primary
question jake show me coffee
oh sorry
i think you have coffee in that i would
love to sip that coffee and find out
there's just vodka flooding it is just i
think the twist at the end is that you
were always a coffee mug to start off
with and really you just turned into a
human it looks awesome i mean it's
really cool i'm excited that arcane has
so they have a studio down in austin
that's working at prey and then the
studio in leon france which is uh
working they worked on designer two so
harvey smith had headed that up uh ralph
cole antonio the other kind of studio
creative head is leading up prey
obviously prey too was a thing by arcane
back in the day they canceled it but
this is like the reimagining it seems
more like a dishonored vein of uh first
person narrative kind of sim game
um with you know choice and consequence
but this is more horror uh sci-fi
obviously as opposed to designers more
steampunk fantasy aesthetic but it's
also open like open i don't know if it's
a pure open world or more of a
metroidvania
um i'm this might be my most anticipated
game of the year uh you know there's
breath of the wild and red dead
redemption 2 and major hits like that
but
i've been replaying dishonored 2 lately
again um and we're doing
we have some stuff planned with arcane
in the near future which you can come
back to
at some point to watch between live
streams and some bigger projects which
i'm excited about but prey might be my
most anticipated game right now i've
been showing rob handler i sit next to
him now uh in the office now that mary
kish left and i've been showing him
prey footage it's awesome i can't wait
for that game when are you going to make
your prey 2 fan art or i guess just pray
what are you what am i going to make it
or when am i going to release
i've already made for the past three
months uh whenever you want it can i get
a hardcover edition sure thank you uh
next episode of the lobby you guys can
ask for it and i'll
show everyone i'm still a little bit
show and tell mike
uh oh still a little bit tainted by like
the original prey that i was shown at
like a judge's week at e3 right two pray
two yeah
they they showed it off as a space
bounty hunter game originally it kind of
looked like the star wars 1313
like thing we always wanted and then
that got cancelled so i have to like
change mindset into portal yeah it's uh
it does look super weird those aliens
can also change into like trash cans so
you have to kind of hit trash cans to
make sure it's not them uh yeah tier in
467 in the twitch chat there is the
release date is may 5th for prey as of
now i doubt they i kind of it's kind of
close creeping up i don't know if it'll
be delayed who knows i think it's
probably a good idea to call every
release date now a preliminary release
date probably yeah we've been wondering
if like andromeda and red dead will be
delayed andromeda i think it's too close
it's too close yeah uh
what's it march is stacked now with the
switch and
all those games tell me about it uh
horizon zero dawn's like three days
before the switch releases which sucks
because i'm really excited to take my
time with that game if you know it looks
cool yeah all right um anyway so that is
kind of our news reel for the day those
are the minor things that happen not
minor but those are the smaller things
that happened this week uh i do have a
giveaway uh gamespot's twitter account
will be tweeting soon i think during the
show you can respond to it and we will
pick a winner thursday
but being is that it's a giveaway you
probably want to know what you're doing
about here you go
turtle beach gaming heads up here wait
i'll give it to pete so you can get a
closer look at it i don't have a single
camera on me uh
that's pete's face this you will not get
that with a giveaway that might be a
future one yeah turtle beach recon 320
headset uh i think it's pc only might i
mean you would know maybe uh yep yeah so
pc only if you play pc games a lot uh
like a bunch of us here at the game spot
office then you can usually
yes so uh i'll try to remember at the
end of the show to remind listeners
again but you can uh respond to
gamespot's tweet about the giveaway and
we will pick a winner thursday i believe
uh shiva she runs our twitter account
she will be going through those replies
and seeing who wins it all right
didn't mean to hit the table too hard at
the table hopefully it's okay i dragged
my vodka mug across the table
we won't spill this corrosive alcohol
over this
pristine table uh sweet so let's get on
to the show a lot of people in the chat
talking about ghost recon aaron you and
jake decker recently got the chance to
play the co-op sandbox which is the part
i'm excited about for the game and i
think a lot of people because at e3 we
played the story mode i think it was uh
timur our uk editor played it was not
too thrilled with it but you also said
the writing was kind of like frat
boy-ish uh let's talk about the story
really quick before we get into what you
like about the game okay yeah like just
we so we played four hours we played on
the ps4 pro
just to clarify the the single player
and the multiplayer are the same game
it's just whether you all have your
friends
take over the
uh your buddies or not
so
yeah like wildlands
there's two games here there's two
separate experiences
there's the one with your friends which
i loved and i thought was incredible
um
the sandbox was so good
and just the moments you have the like
the nail buddy moments you have where
like you're about to die and like over
the radio your friend's like i got this
and you see like
a shot from a hilltop take out the guy
who's about to kill you and then your
friend buzzes in with a little bird like
right as you get revived and you get in
and then you peel out and like dodge a
sam
and like go fly off and do something
else that part i loved and i thought was
incredible like it delivered some of the
things i've wanted
to do with friends and like even games
like arma for a long time
the barrier to entry was so high that i
just could never get a group of friends
together to do it right for how much it
looks like they're going for realism in
this well are they i mean ghost recon
has always been is well for the future
soldier obviously they went
to the future um and now they
are they going for more realistic bent
in this columbia because you're battling
like drug cartels i wonder if it's gonna
be some sort of
actual you know social commentary on i
mean future future soldier in an open
world is accurate now the the story
which you asked me about i thought in
the first four hours was just straight
up bad
um
so you like land in central america and
everybody in central america completely
trusts you which is weird because like
there's a long history of american
intervention
and things going really shitty
in central america
and
like on top of that
it's just
like it's just super like team america
world police and it's not self-aware and
like everybody's just always cracking
out of place dick jokes and like yeah
it's you know it's that plot like hey if
we just go kill all the drug dealers
everything's gonna turn out great in
bolivia
it's just the complete like lack of
awareness of
events in central america and how crappy
the war on drugs have been and like
again from a story perspective there are
ways that you can do this that are more
impactful for example if the soldiers
start if the soldiers know that history
which they would if their elite delta
operatives and start questioning why
they're there or if they're going to
have any impact
or you can go the call of duty like ac
130 mission where it's super clinical
language to the point where these people
come across as
like disconnected from the people who
they're killing like there's ways to
write a game like this
where in addition to the the fun stuff
you're doing there's impact on the
player
like some of that is because this game
is completely non-linear
so there you do not have to do the story
in any order you can do it completely
out of order okay
and like i get that puts developers in a
bit of a bind where
it's hard to build character when
players can just screw off and do
anything at any time yeah so i don't
know like they have this challenge they
have this great sandbox
um they got motorcycles whoa
wait did you uh yeah bolivia south
america a few people are pointing out
what did you say central did i say
central yeah i believe south america
yeah just to clarify um so it
from what did you ever play um did you
play future soldier i did did you play
that co-op mode that was uh sort of like
a horde mode but every five waves you
had to infiltrate stealthily and kill
everybody
you had synced shots in that so i'm
wondering if it kind of feels like
future soldier in an open world but with
a little more emerging gameplay i think
it's exactly future soldier in an open
world okay which sounds cool because i
actually liked future soldier more than
i think the average person yeah
and again like
i
kind of thought the story was mediocre
and the writing was kind of bad but as
soon as you get your friends in there
it's it's a great game like it is
actually a really really fun game and it
like you know again like you see here
you're assaulting a base at night with a
lightning storm you are like using your
night vision goggles you're scouting
with your recon drone
um you are planning combined arnold
combine armed assaults with your friends
like coming in with little bird
helicopters dusting off on a rooftop
like dropping off a sniper on a hillside
that aspect of this game
like
that's what made it the experience
that's what made the four hours for me
is it um
what do you want to say for the actual
is there pvp in the game uh adam a
day 8 i aim
on twitter sorry if i mispronounced that
was asking if there will be pvp in this
game at all assuming there will be some
sort they haven't talked about it um so
we don't know but
you know again this game has a lot of
potential i think there's only a couple
games out there that do combined arms
multiplayer like battlefield
and i'm not saying that they would go
that direction in the future with this
game
but
doing pvp in in an open world
environment i think is
i mean you know ju people have
mod modded just cause two and three to
have multiplayer sure and i think this
game could also
benefit from it hold on just cause three
has multiplayer now in a mod they modded
it in yeah
how does that work
it's insane tangent
yeah i mean by that i mean
are there tanks flying around with mines
attached to them and people flying into
said tanks i mean with their own minds
it is just cos so
if you can imagine it sweet so
i know what i want to do after the show
now um do you think ghost recon will
turn out like the division did last year
asks gamer votes
uh the game looks promising but then
again the division was also super hyped
it's funny as soon as the division came
out we had a traffic spike in people
searching for ghost recon wildlands
because i think we all know the division
for a lot of people
was way too much of an rpg and not
enough of a shooter
this game is a shooter which i like i
love the gun customization it had some
of my favorite weapons and rifles you
have to go through the world and collect
all the the scopes and weapon parts and
then you take him in a gunsmith
but also like a boss showed up there was
a mission we did through a tunnel that
was really fun we started with backhoes
because you can drive anything in this
game right um except for llamas which i
can't hold against the devs but i kind
of wanted to drive a llama
jake decker
right here so that little cross that was
the boss um he
i accidentally killed him he he walked
into a gunfight and i hit him with an
errant like 320 grenade round and he
died instantly you just walk into a
gunfight
man where did i leave my phone
it was all the cocaine he was hopped out
you guys seen my croquet mallet oh yeah
did you um ricky n on twitter was saying
did you get a sense of how big the world
was yeah obviously all open worlds now
are big but like did it seem did you get
a sense of it being pretty vast did you
get a chance to look at the mini map or
anything yeah the we played two
regions like maybe a tenth of the game
we spent about four hours there
it's weird
the size of a world is usually a good
talking point for developers but it has
pros and cons because the problem with
an open world game is you have to fill
it with stuff like this is a general
ubisoft
challenge in all of their games
and if you make the game too big and you
fill it with too much boring stuff or
you make too much stuff that distracts
people from the main quests or
you sacrifice you know the textures up
close in this game weren't very good but
like the environmental effects at a
distance like lightning storms and
flamingos you know
you're flying through a flock of
flamingos with your helicopter or
just the the things in the distance were
all gorgeous but the things up close
were kind of yeah meh so i don't know
yeah it's a massive world they're saying
it's the biggest one they've ever made
that comes with
pros and cons
more play time more things to do
question is the big question is always
how well did you fill that world with
stuff and how fun is that stuff to do
yeah you can make chicago and watch dogs
one but if there aren't that many people
it won't feel like a city that's why i
like the division i thought it was
kind of boring that way it was this
beautiful city with no people in it yeah
and i had no antivirus right yeah yeah i
guess they justified that but i don't
know i didn't find the division too fun
but i haven't played since like what
they've done a year of updates now it's
just a totally different game from what
i hear
their survival dlc literally is a
different game right
yeah that's how i want to play the game
when i
i said this
all throughout the year in the office
and also in my free time and also on the
lobby people who have been here a lot
i'm sure goob shoe riot is probably
saying
has heard this before but i've been
meaning to play more of the division
since release day by the way it was
almost a year ago in like yeah i still
want to like me and you were the ones
saying like oh i love the
post-apocalyptic aesthetic in new york i
love like that kind of rag tag group of
people fighting back and i tried playing
the game like the mechanics just totally
kind of screwed it up for me
unfortunately oh well i think that game
got sunk on just a general sense of
unfairness like i think the mechanics i
think even the cover mechanics were
unfair to the players
you had no fine control over
coming up and over cover you get shot
during animations going out of cover
there was no crouch there was no prone
right like and then you get in the dark
zone and other players with better gear
would instantly kill you and not even
take your stuff like you didn't even
want to take what i had you just did it
to be a dick just give you a taste of
their taint and move on yeah so david
fox and the twitch chat was just asking
aaron how easy is it to kind of
coordinate with your team because in the
e3 demo obviously ubisoft was they're
all converging on one base
at a time as a cohesive unit
did it seem that easy or like how does
it kind of keep the team together in
this massive open world can you have
like one person in each corner so
they're from what you played there are
actually really cool mechanics in the
game that give you situational awareness
when you each of you can pick a target
so if you're trying to do like a four
person sync shot each of you can
designate a target and everybody else on
your team sees what target that you are
aiming at
and they can also see if you're not
aiming at that target so if you all
designate a target and somebody's about
to initiate a countdown which you can do
with a button press or just count down
yourselves okay
if you see a circle go over one of the
one of the guys who you've targeted you
know that your your buddy's screwing
around and not aiming at that guy
so like steve
or like yeah i mean that's a cool
military name that's why they use last
name so you're not saying like take the
shot doug
uh jake decker uh video producer here
who played the co-op with you was just
telling um
david fox if i'm not mistaken who asked
the question that you get a notification
when they want to do a mission and then
you can accept and fast travel yeah so
we like that we found the easiest thing
to do was to break there's four people
in co-op we broke off into teams of two
and like talked between teams of two
because honestly sync shotting with two
people's way easier
um
i mean there's always the chance of
somebody to go full leroy jenkins when
you're trying to do a stealth run
because the stealth has a lot of good
mechanics to it and there's a lot of
planning that can go into it
and if you screw it up i was impressed
with how hard the ai pushed back it's
like gta they'll just kill they'll kill
you eventually
so you either have to do the stealth
route or you have to have an exit plan
okay um
and how much you accomplish in the
meantime how much stuff you get done in
the base is kind of up to you and how
stealthy
or not stealthy or quick you decide to
do it okay
so the
it was pretty easy with the right crowd
right when you're playing with other
people yeah it seems like the division
kind of it could be make or made or
break
made or broken by who you're playing
with if you're playing with someone you
know or like left 4 dead or something i
don't know you can also just use games
now that i think of it like you can be
in the same world with your friends and
choose not to do missions with them
right so you can actually be just doing
other stuff and then it's like it was
just left on the d-pad join up and go do
something together and then go off and
do whatever else you want
that was pretty
pretty seamless and easy cool so in
general it seems like wildlands at least
from your perspective right now the
co-op sandbox is where it's at as
opposed to the kind of more
less than optimistic story yeah and
again when we play the first four hours
there's a chance that maybe there'll be
a story arc later on in the game that
kind of points out shooting drug dealers
doesn't
solve problems yeah like the movie
traffic sicario pretty much every movie
about drugs
drug trade but the co-op
is doing stuff that i love when you're
with your friends okay cool uh you and
jake also did i think it's up now on the
site on gamespot the six things you
should know about ghost recon wildlands
so people watching right now you can go
check that on the site
right now uh you can watch that for more
in-depth conversation about the game and
let us know what you think we'll do our
best to look through the comments and
kind of answer any other questions that
weren't answered in the future or on
this segment
all right
we can move on to yakuza yes first
the real reason everyone is watching
this show
yeah
sorry we're having a behind the scenes
snafu uh yes yakuza 0 is the one i have
jean luc i told him to queue up the live
stream with you and rob which part yeah
which part um
i don't know uh jean luke if you have
something up right now that you want to
roll we can throw that up just to give
people a sense of what how yakuza zero
roll that beautiful footage yeah
it'll roll every second we'll keep
talking
here we go uh all right here we go oh
man uh pete explain to me what's going
on
so this is a game about hardcore
criminals
who backstab each other
um look the yakuza series is um
something that's been like bubbling
under the surface for years and and
people
really love it and it seems like every
game that passes
that crowd doesn't really grow for
whatever reason it it maybe people have
a hard time jumping in but yakuza 0 is
the perfect entry point because it is a
prequel to the original game
so you don't need to know anything about
the characters maybe if you do you'll
appreciate the story more but really
this is a good excuse to finally play
yakuza if you've been wondering about it
uh and this is the first one i've
finished and
the games i've played before like the
same thing is present here where you
have this juxtaposition between
very serious storytelling about
criminals trying to you know work their
way through the ranks right but also be
loyal and good friends to the people
that matter to them um but also try to
figure out like do they really matter to
me are they my good friend so there's a
lot of sort of like betrayal and stuff
that happens like that but then when you
aren't engaged with the story
you are doing one of two things you are
either
uh fighting people uh which is not one
of the game's strong suits it has this
sort of very simple arcadey beat-em-up
thing that would feel uh oh god here we
go
uh this you know beat em up component
that feels like it belongs in like a
late 90s early 3d arcade game um
[ __ ] all right don't get derailed by the
software porn about to come up all right
so i mean that in
a literal way possible a very literal
way um and then you have these other
pursuits where you can go around town
and you can play arcade games you can uh
go out to restaurants you can do karaoke
you can disco dance um you can watch
essentially porn
right up close to this old crtv just
chilling with your ashtray and your box
of tissues
and no shame
cbs is going to come kick in the studio
door seriously when it's just an
exercise video what are you talking
about
she's not an exerciser she's on an
exercise ball i can't watch this anyway
look away from the tv keep going with
what you're saying why did you get this
game you gave this game an eight out of
ten yeah
so you were saying it's just weird blend
of uh melodrama and just like taking
yourself just not seriously absurdist
comedy right so like yes you have these
weird things they're like okay yeah this
is uncomfortable and strange but okay
but it's
phew good thing
[Music]
it's the pursuits are not just like
wacky things like softcore porn right
you also uh you get to meet the citizens
in these recreations of cities in in
japan this case would be a part of tokyo
and a part of osaka
um and these random citizens need help
with certain things right like one girl
is sort of like hey you i've been lying
to my dad about having a boyfriend
you happen to look just like the guy
described and this is when you're
playing as a character who's like six
feet tall menacing with an eye patch and
she's like no that's that's how i
described my fake boyfriend to my dad
okay and so you have to like go sit down
to dinner with her father and sort of
like and she's like by the way he's very
strict he's very picky and you have to
like give him the right answers to make
sure that
you're not like blowing her cover mm-hmm
and but like it's the ending isn't just
like oh you convinced the dad or you
didn't i won't spoil it but there's a
wrinkle that that [ __ ] that shows up and
that sort of thing is present in all
these little side stories at first it
seems like just an excuse to introduce
something stupid and silly but but it
finds a way to just like endear itself
to you a little bit more by making it
about uh like an unexpected little twist
so you've been telling me that you don't
actually kill many people in this game
which is striking because i just watched
him beat the [ __ ] out of someone with a
bicycle and a giant urn yeah i mean you
will grind people's face in the pavement
you will you know slam them skull first
into the ground like you just do all
sorts of things that should easily kill
somebody but
that's sort of
you know that
combat falls into the more comedic side
of the game than it does the serious
story part
and i say serious because the story
really does take itself seriously it
does not goof around at all
uh in no way shape or form uh the same
way the rest of the game does yeah so
it's this awesome little like palette
cleanser and this nice balance um and
the game is also really accessible in
terms of figuring out okay what's my
next destination for the story you
always know so at any time you can just
say look i'm going to screw around for a
minute and you want to get back to the
story you can do it immediately so it's
like a it's a buffet of these various
things that you can just easily get to
and enjoy for what they are um and you'd
think that it would spoil the other
halfs because they're so different but
it works in concert because you don't
really
have to do the funny stuff if you don't
want to it's there just for you to enjoy
and this guy's about to cut his pinky
off that's hilarious oh man these guys
watch so what's really interesting is
that you look at these character models
uh some of them like this guy is based
on a real world actor uh but anyway
these characters all primary characters
in the game whether they're based off a
real world character or not
look pretty good but all npcs look like
crap like look like
uprez ps2 models with new textures like
outside of cutscenes outside of cut
scenes but but you know yeah and it's
it's kind of jarring to an extent but
again this game it's an open world it's
not huge but it's got a lot of depth to
it there are there are 100 side stories
to follow
probably a dozen different mini games
which includes baseball karaoke bowling
darts disco dancing softcore porn
uh betting on girls
fighting uh like
yeah i know okay there's
it's
it's a game that doesn't really like you
know hide its roots as being rooted in
late 80s japan and it's about yakuza
which you know it's not really that
great towards women so you have to be
you know you kind of have to roll your
eyes a little bit and get over that fact
it doesn't make it right it just sort of
makes it one of those things depending
on your tastes sure um whether it's
authentic or not for the time period
yeah i mean it's still worth it i mean i
get that it still made me uncomfortable
at times yeah i'm not a prude by any
measure but there's still some scenes
where it's just like god damn like they
really are treating women like [ __ ] yeah
um so but you know what that's it's a
really small part of the game uh so i
don't want to harp on that for too long
it's just important to consider if those
things are important to you you might
have mentioned this already uh
but i kind of got distracted by the game
in general
being here right now the software porn
and the this the stomping heads uh but
it's yakuza 0 because it's a prequel to
the series correct um before the first
game presumably yeah and there are let's
see
six
main story games there is yakuza dead
souls
uh and then
so the the remake of the first game
yakuza kiwami is coming out this summer
and then we're getting yakuza six down
the road so that's six is the next
sequel coming up yes so in order to play
the let's see it would be two three four
and five you need a ps2 and a ps3 those
games are only available on those
platforms yeah it's weird that there's
what there's gonna be a seek a sixth
game plus zero plus the remake
seems like a huge series obviously i've
i've played dead souls and it's got
spin-offs like dead souls and dead souls
is like nothing like the major series
right
i mean there's also one set in feudal
japan yeah that unfortunately we're not
gonna get in the west unless things
yakuza 0 is selling out on amazon in
most countries really so this is i think
the first one where people are
kind of willing to jump in um so who
knows we might get that eventually maybe
sega of japan will you know because
honestly like western sales really do
dictate a lot of what happens in japan
in terms of game development now yeah so
who knows maybe the success of zero the
presumed success will lead to more of
these games being remade or being ported
or localized yeah let's hope so again
dead souls is the first time i played
and only but yeah zero's kind of
tempting just because of everything i'm
seeing and hearing dude and i put like
50 to 60 hours in this game and my
completion percentage was 16
damn there is so much to do with that if
you if you really enjoy this i mean
it'll last you 100 hours if not more
damn that sounds awesome uh aaron have
you played a yakuza game before my
experience with yakuza is occasionally
look over my shoulder and see really
weird [ __ ] going on on peter's
monitor and i'm like he must be playing
yakuza again this year
this it's that time of year whenever it
cuts to a clean xbox i know
it's peter playing yakuza pete's got one
on hand
i keep a small one in my pocket clean
xbox a little pocket tissue thing oh
nice that's actually a thing you get in
the game i won't go into it no matter
your lunch breaks no you collect
so there's a cop you meet who likes to
frisk you and he wants to make sure that
you don't have any contraband on you and
there's people who are constantly
handing out free samples like they kind
of do in cities in japan and so you can
just get pocket tissues at infinitum and
you can just essentially use those to
show the cop that you're a good person
gotcha no weapons no drugs nothing like
that well your full review is up on
gamespot now you give it an 8 out of 10.
you like this game a lot i do yeah what
are some of the drawbacks
very inconsistent graphics um combat
that does grow a little bit repetitive
uh despite the creativity that you can
have with the the takedown moves
um
that's kind of it you know like it
it does a really good job at most
everything else rodrigo guinyame i
believe in the youtube chat is also
pretty uh astounded that you only
completed 16 after that much time i know
i mean i finished the story that 16
includes the story plus all side content
so i did i think
30 side stories and played about 10
hours or so of like the mini games you
know plus side story stuff here's a mini
game right here with a guy in tidy white
he's in an alleyway oh yeah so this is
walking erection um that's his name yes
you meet him oh you're serious i'm
serious that was a joke on my part
you meet him
and he's just in the subtitles in the
subtitles walking erection says
so basically you meet this guy and he's
like hey i just saw that you were in
this club last night so you must like uh
like i do he's like trust me if you ever
need to find me need some advice on how
to get off i'm everywhere he talks about
how often he gets off like yeah why is
it mr libido now it keeps changing his
name i think it's it's based on the
context of what you learn about the
character moment-to-moment what yeah
because apparently his libido is like
his pride because he can get off like
six times a day so he just does never
satisfy he just goes to sit ups and gets
off all day yeah awesome yeah that's the
life yeah good for him man that's why
he's always smiling always got a
six-pack and he's just endorphins
rushing through his body almost at all
times among other things
all right
sweet enough of that uh yeah go play
that game it sounds like i want to now
not because of the walking erection or
the softcore porn um i want to walk for
the melodrama and the serious things
that make me sound like an intelligent
human being
actually a very low brow
person that
so thrown off uh yeah seriously go read
pete's review it's on gamespot.com uh
did you notice how the viewer count
jumped almost doubled
through porno we found out the stream to
the secret algorithm we found out the
secret to getting people in our streams
we just put software porn on yeah
seriously cbs is gonna like repel into
this room and
take us out all right anyways for the
third time go read that review it's good
the game sounds awesome i'm looking
forward to playing it
all right aaron this time for real i'm
going to bring scott butterworth on the
set the rest of the show is pretty much
resident evil 7. sweet you didn't get to
talk too much during zero but then again
why would we talk when we get such
awesome i didn't need to talk with
footage like that
uh yeah no it spoke for itself all right
thanks for coming on and talking ghost
recon there and i will see you later
cool thanks mike
later um
did you play much resident evil 7 um
like an hour and a half in i haven't
played anymore since we talked yesterday
okay we got like a few segments talking
about vr and talking about whether it
should be your first game scott
butterworth game spot editor you
reviewed the game for us i did but let's
just talk about yakuza that's amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh i haven't played
yoku zero but i do love that series like
yakuza is amazing so if yeah if you
haven't played those games for some
reason totally go play them they're
ridiculous play the games yeah yeah
that's like what we were the main focus
of that was why you should care about
yeah because if you don't but it seems
like you said it's sold out on amazon it
sounds like a lot of people do i think
it's still available in the us on amazon
but like canada and a few other places i
think in canada
what's that uh bob evans and uh what's
the other the coffee place oh horton
horton timberlands tim hortons i'm just
naming guys
tim hortons and yakuza zero canadian way
yeah
the national sport of canada is not
hockey it is lacrosse incidentally you
would know that i know
top cheddar sports
uh all right sweet so let's get right
into it yeah scott you gave resident
evil 7 biohazard and 8 out of 10 on your
review i did it's just as good as yakuza
0.
that's exactly what it's saying very
very different no in the same ways
that's what eight out of 10 means yeah
i feel like there was very little sexual
release in resident evil i mean at least
for me so not from
not for me
i enjoyed resident evil 7 a lot
uh so you you've beaten it as well now
right i did yeah um i did it in two
sittings
which i don't recommend but that's the
thing about resident evil 7 before i get
your opinion i
think the pacing is
really good like you mentioned in your
review some sections dragged and i do
agree but even those section i was
i really really like that you know we're
going to avoid spoilers but
throughout the game it's pretty
impressive how capcom kind of stuck to
its survival horror guns yeah totally
throughout the game uh it it's not
resonable six it's not five or four yeah
not even a little bit it's seven as the
number denotes uh yeah even though
sections that kind of drag you still
want to know what comes next right so
you feel like okay i'm going to slog
through this because i care because like
whatever's next it's like i want to get
there whether through gameplay or story
because for the first time in the series
spin-offs or numbered the story's
comprehensible yeah yeah it's very
far-fetched but it's comprehensible yeah
i mean it's still a little outlandish in
places because it's resident evil and
like it gets a little silly but like it
was never so silly that i was like this
is just dumb it was just like okay like
i would accept the conceit and move on
and yeah ultimately it is like as far as
resident evil is concerned a very
grounded story a story that makes sense
from start to finish there is this
cohesion to the entire experience and it
totally goes some places i did not
expect which is great it wasn't just a
you know like like i put in the review
without spoiling too much there is more
to this game than what you have seen of
it so far for sure uh yeah because right
now it's just that very technical texas
chainsaw massacre vibe there are some
clear uh influences from other like
specific horror franchises that goes
into this and we uh just to pimp it i'm
going to do it a lot because it's really
good timor hussein uk editor and adam
mason over in the uk uh in collaboration
with a couple people here who helped
they did uh one of our game spot studios
documentary series the two-part series
on
making resident evil 7 and also just
resident evil series influence as a
whole on the horror genre we talked to a
bunch of people that worked on
resident evil 7 which is kind of a
all-star team of resident evil past
resident evil devs uh massachusetts on
it takeuchi worked on
uh resident evil 7 and the series is
really good you should go watch it's on
gamespots on youtube uh tamar did a
really good job behind the scenes stuff
just a lot of insight i spoke to dan
pinchbeck from uh the chinese room who
made an amnesia machine for pigs he was
a great interview i like that yeah
and also uh someone from alien isolation
his name escapes me right now he was
like head on isolation i wish i knew his
name but also matthias warsh from dead
space how uh residual four and also the
earlier games influenced dead space but
uh yeah go check that out there's my uh
first of probably several plugs for that
series it's fantastic you should watch
it um absolutely and we've actually done
a few series like that but like this may
be the best one it's it's really
genuinely some of the best content we've
we've played it's really good if you
like resident evil it is especially
awesome i mean and what's interesting
though is i think resident evil and part
of the excitement around returning to
survival horror right and getting back
to the series roots it is just such a
recognizable name it is like an
inescapable part of gamer culture at
large so even people who aren't
necessarily horror fans resident evil
fans i think might actually get
something out of that series just
because of how influential the early
games were i mean like years of war yeah
and there you go there's a war in dead
space and all these other franchises
[ __ ] and otherwise yeah absolutely were
influenced by resident evil so and it's
weird that it dropped off i mean it's
not weird it dropped then and silent
hill dropped off the map kind of the two
flagship horror series and you know now
resident evil 7's back in a good way
it's getting pretty positive reception
across the board uh yeah my eight was on
the low end yeah for most of the scores
that i was seeing right i think i saw
one seven i figured where it was but
everything else was pretty high um yeah
so just to go back to your review uh in
terms of to get into the details
what do you like
i don't know walk us through what your
experience with it after you finish the
game what was kind of going through your
head um i mean like i said i i did it in
a day uh which it's like a 12-hour game
they're saying give or take an hour yeah
i mean i could see
beating it i mean i think you said you
beat in like seven like or seven and a
half save time was seven and a half i
think i spent like nine on it okay
but i also as a i played four hours of
this for the resident evil 7 studios to
help out with uh in japan so you kind of
knew some of the parts so that section i
kind of
knew what i was doing gotcha um but
there are puzzles in this game they're
not that hard but like navigating the
mansion and uh other places is part of
what's gonna take a little bit but the
backtracking
worked i think yeah i mean there's not
there's not too much of it and it's like
ninety 90 of it's optional it's
basically oh hey you now have a key that
opens a door that you walk past you want
to go get some more items like go for it
go back and get that stuff but you don't
you don't need it it'll just help you
sure um so i think that that was a wise
choice on their part by and large it is
a relatively linear experience i mean
there's actually sort of a hub and spoke
structure to certain parts of the game
where you can you know shoot out and do
something and come back to your little
like safe spot and then go out again and
do something but yeah still like the
series of events there's really only one
next thing to do at any given time so it
really drives the experience forward
makes it very clear what you need to be
doing so yeah i didn't i didn't mind the
backtracking at all it really was just
the survival horror like hey if you need
more stuff and if you're patient go back
and get it or just forge ahead and take
your chances sure uh to use an
overworked overused term uh kind of
metroidvania aspect or castle roid as
council said yeah i think that's
something that's a fair spot came up
with that that term castle right yeah i
can't because metroidvania i think
jeremy parrish the the journalist
popularized it but i think in a recent
thing about symphony of the night which
actually has its 20th anniversary in
march i think we're gonna do something
fun with that um he was saying he didn't
actually coin it with someone else at
usgamer or something at that time it was
probably at that time for him one up
right oh yeah because your former one up
as well as justin is yeah i didn't work
that close with jeremy gotcha anyway but
yeah so in terms of backtracking and
opening up new areas
no uh yeah it's actually uh
it the game itself any time i
backtracked it felt
there's still more items i hadn't picked
up or there's always something going
through my head in terms of do i want to
use this chem fluid to make handgun ammo
or should i save it for health if i
think i'm coming up on a boss fight or
something it's that cool that's survival
which the item management which hasn't
really been present resident evil since
four but in a big way since like the
first three games yeah totally um
yeah so inventory management definitely
makes a big return and i mean it also
just that
enhances the tension in a lot of ways
right because you know one enemy swipes
at you and like it's not gonna kill you
but just that one hit hurts so much more
because you're like ah now i'm gonna
have to spend a healing item to recover
my health and like i don't know when i'm
going to get another one so even even
little moments that aren't going to kill
you or force you to restart are suddenly
way more high stakes just because of the
inventory management because everything
is so scarce right can i ask you a
little bit of a question yeah so i'm
about hour and a half into the game and
it seems like health items have been
pretty plentiful
so does that continue i will say that so
the hardest difficulty you can play on
out of the box is normal and you
eventually unlock something harder um
but on normal i feel like the game is
consistently generous enough that if you
are patient and vigilant you will always
find what you need yeah like if you're
just blazing through you will die and
run out of items but if you are taking
your time and you're meticulously
searching rooms yeah you will find
enough stuff because that is what i'm
doing okay yeah i am like turning over
every stone just to make sure i would
say that on normal there's a pretty
pretty good balance of
being tense without being punishing i
still feel like i don't want to use my
items but frankly like when i do and
then i'm like okay i'll find one in the
next room and it's like oh all right i
guess i shouldn't have cared so much i
do think that that drops off a little
bit the further you get in but not
significantly reach a point in the game
where it's like suddenly you have
nothing and you're just screwed
like no it's but um i do feel like the
frequency does decline as you would
expect yeah it should the later you get
in the game the more difficult it's
going to be the higher the stakes the
higher the tension the better you should
be yeah absolutely um and you do get
better like you will you sort of learn
how to fight the enemies that you face
in the game and like that was actually
sort of one of my issues with the game
that i feel like just sort of the basic
enemies that you encountered to the game
could have been a little more capable
once you sort of understand them you
realize like i can just
run away from these idiots like whatever
um not always the case but if you see
them from a distance you're like i'm not
gonna fight you i don't and you can just
kind of run away and how persistent are
enemies
depends on the enemy there's the there's
the gamey thing if you play a lot of
resident evils you know that they'll
abide by the rule that if you're in a
safe room they won't go in so you know
that so much but like there's some you
know like in the the manor you start off
right there's a lot like especially
around the kitchen and the dining room
the living room like there's a lot of
like space there for that are that are
connected
um i know one person character will
follow you relentlessly but oh there are
some sections that are more like
resident evil 3 nemesis kind of a
persistent threat not throughout the
game though um i'd say
by and large
most of the game there are enemies tied
to certain areas like so if i leave that
area will the enemy still be there when
i go back so here's here's what i'll say
um i think that
resident evil 7 does a really excellent
job of seamlessly stitching together a
bunch of different components and you
don't realize that you've actually
transitioned from one section of the
game into the next section yeah and
different sections are governed by
different enemies and different sort of
like ai in a way so there there will be
a section where there's almost a tyrant
like character who will just
relentlessly come after you and there
are other sections where it behooves you
to be a little stealthier just because
that's what's going to work for you and
again you don't it's not explicit it's
not like you know a big prompt comes up
and says hey you need to be stealthy
here but you just sort of as a character
intuitively understand what's happening
around you and suddenly the gameplay
will pivot slightly and now you're in
this other type of section so really
depends on the portion of the game that
you're in okay it is really yeah it is
really fluid in how it goes from
one type of horror like jump scares to
another which is more dread and being
chased and then to another one where
you're like do i want to use this uh
advanced handgun ammo to kill this enemy
or do i want to say the shotgun for the
next room are there gonna be booby traps
in this room it does
you put it really well it does
transition between those without you
really realizing it it makes it feel
like one cohesive
game rather than these separate sections
like these kind of bite-sized you know
like mini chapters which totally kind of
is but but it doesn't there's no like a
there's not like a chapter marker now
you're done it just fluidly moves to the
next thing i i will say that just in
general variety is one of the core
strengths of resident evil 7. again
certain sections kind of drag after a
while because you end up doing similar
things from start to finish but in
between you will find all kinds of
different subtle shades of horror
gameplay
so it's nice that there are options it's
nice that there are different approaches
and different styles of gameplay all
sort of under the same banner all
presented in a seamless way sure um yeah
there were people asking questions about
uh the dlc did you guys read too much
about that yeah the band footage dlc
what is this about you know um so we
have to check the site to get like exact
details but basically it's going to be
just sort of standalone story segments
so there are going to be two packs of
banned footage pac one pack two i
believe the first one's out in just a
few weeks the next one's out a few weeks
after that so they're both scheduled to
come out relatively soon and both
contain three different things um i
think like two sort of story driven
components and one sort of fun bonus
mode in both cases i don't remember
exactly what the content is um but all
of it is sort of a supplement to the
game it's not really like and here is
the next chapter of the story like
here's the you know epilogue to the game
it's stuff that kind of slots into the
universe and is like just purely
optional we'll sort of flesh out other
characters that you interact with or
other you know stuff that happens prior
to the game things like that sure um
that's my understanding of what's
happening uh so photoshop pro and the
youtube chat was just asking and i
actually don't want you to answer this
fully because i think that could lead
into spoilers but it does give me a good
question he says with the demo part of
the story and by that i'm assuming in
the beginning hour demo there's also the
lantern demo or is the full game of
continuation from the demo i think
that's spoiler territory but you were
talking yesterday about how you thought
it was really cool about the pre-release
like marketing how that plays a part in
the story can you talk about that
without spoiling anything
not really however uh i am generally i'm
already working on a feature um that i
would so when you see this feature hit
the site i would recommend beating the
game before you re-watch this but i do
think that the way capcom handled sort
of their pre-release build up to this
game in a really interesting way that's
not unprecedented but
is something that i think is truly
remarkable and actually like i totally
applaud the way that they approach
things yes um so if i really explain
what i mean i will be spoiling things
but um
i i do think that if you were paying
attention before the game come out if
you're playing the demo that you're
going to find some really cool stuff in
in the game and you're going to be very
happy that you were paying attention
before the game came out awesome uh so
in terms of your review quick bullet
points before we move on to the next
section good bad overall thoughts
good variety um good return to horror i
think it did an excellent job i do think
it was paced well um
some of the boss fights were really
amazing like true resident evil boss
fights the story is actually very good
uh surprisingly good it avoids a lot of
pitfalls that it could have easily
fallen into and instead does something
kind of unexpected and a lot of the
twists are predictable but it's so cool
to see them play out
bad would be i do think like i said
certain sections kind of drag or it's
just like okay i just want to get
through this i don't actually care about
what i'm doing i just want to get to the
next thing that happens a few times a
couple of the boss battles were actually
more annoying than intense i think
that's the way i phrased it definitely
uh there's one in particular where uh
you're given a weapon just for that
fight and i kept dying over and over
until the game said by the way you can
do a power attack if you hit these
buttons and as soon as it told me that i
won the fight i actually need to tell
you something else about that fight that
uh someone from capcom told me about
yeah that there's something else that
makes that fight really easy really i
didn't know about it i didn't know about
what you told me until yeah sorry we're
inside baseball [ __ ] yeah we're always
one of those things um
i think that those are the those are the
big negatives i also wish they'd done a
little more with puzzles there are a
couple really great puzzles in the game
i just wish there had been more of them
cool uh yes so go read scott's review it
is up on gamespot he gave an eight out
of ten results 7 biohazard he liked it a
lot as a lot of outlets seem to be uh
corroborating that and myself as well
it's a great game pete probably play
more of it soon i assume yeah i like it
a lot so far it's definitely like a nice
uh change of pace cool and we got a few
more resident evil segments but again
watch our reviving resident evil series
uh tomorrow saying the uk editor did a
great job with that behind the scenes we
have a lot of guides going up soon like
what the beating the game will unlock uh
how new game plus works a guide for
finding antique coins these things that
unlock more abilities and uh weapons how
resident people ties into the broader
universe yes uh which we're actually
about to get to in a little bit so we're
talking more about how residual fits
into the resident evil franchise
but for all intents purposes it seems
like capcom has a winner on their hands
and maybe they're kind of you know the
series seems like it is making a
comeback which is great for everyone so
yeah go check those out the site and uh
leave your thoughts in the comments
we'll do our best to peruse them and
answer any questions we might not have
answered here
cool now i want to split focus
specifically uh you raised the idea of
doing this segment scott because
jean-luc psyche who's uh manning the
tricaster right now right now as we
speak yes he they're in the wings he did
uh he's working on a feature well so he
put up something about our reactions to
residual 7 and vr but he's also working
on a feature he played through the
entire game for the first time in vr
so we were all kind of thinking that's
kind of unprecedented right not maybe
not unprecedented but like we played
we've all played a lot of vr games by
this point pete you've been following vr
for a long time and last year was when
all three headsets released
at least the bigger headsets and
resident evil 7 seems kind of like scott
you said it was like kind of watershed
moment for vr because it's
one of the most well-known aaa
franchises
and then you have people on psvr
probably the most accessible headset i
would say uh they're playing through
this game this horror game seems like a
pretty big moment
so we want to talk about what kind of uh
what resident evil 7 means for vr psvr
specifically but maybe even like broader
terms um did you get the chance to play
in vr yet uh no i haven't yet i mean i
played a lot of horror first-person
stuff sure so i mean so there are the
obvious comments you can make it's more
immersive it's probably scarier it is
scarier in this case um but i think this
game really really
nails the vr because well hey there's
the controls you could see mary kish
former producer
as of last week on screen right now
you're aiming there's a there's an
option and i highly recommend it to aim
with your head uh the reticle follows
where you're looking there's nick
margarita [ __ ] his pants
uh probably swearing a lot
in that video yes we had to beep a lot
of that um
yes and then there's myself
uh there is legs crossed yes casual oh
i'm cool no worries
there's killing some monsters don't
worry about me there's something to be
said about the fact that this is such an
atmospheric um you know
tonal game right it's very much it looks
like texas chainsaw massacre just
dilapidated mansion uh kind of like dank
corridors
uh very
very eerie and it works it's not just
this
uh well here they lie was another psvr
demo that comes to mind and i don't
think it worked really well it was just
this i don't know capcom nailed it what
was your experience with vr in residence
7 scott
so it's kind of a mix experience um for
me so i will say that yeah like
watershed moment was definitely the term
i use and i think it is i mean this is a
huge franchise franchise that that
really takes vr seriously i mean you
have a huge set of options that you can
choose from sorry gumshoe
ryan's taryn nick margarita called nick
that was mine
i thought swamp goblins feel so much
more at home in this setting
nick margarita is a new jersey mud punk
uh moving on scott sorry hasn't seen our
vr reactions video it's very sorry i'm
so sorry we have the chat up right in
front of scott you were speaking so
intelligently and then all of a sudden
we talk about swamp goblins
way better sorry continue
all i was gonna say is that i really
admire that they went all out like they
really took vr seriously with resident
evil 7 you have a ton of different
options that are designed to you know
minimize any uh ill effects that you may
experience while playing vr you can
adjust it so that hitting the right
stick moves the camera in degrees which
for a lot of people actually helps with
motion sickness super customizable yeah
you can also make it smooth you can make
it so that crouch happens automatically
or that you like the camera will move
down
all kinds of options like that so
whatever works for you as a vr player
you can probably create a set of
settings that will best accommodate your
needs as a vr player that is something i
haven't seen from a franchise this huge
i mean this is a big you know 10 to 12
hour
aaa experience that really goes all in
on vr and that's that hasn't really
happened yet it's kind of interesting to
me how they're not really like trying to
like hammer it into people's heads
they're like play this in vr you know
what i mean like i actually appreciate
that but yeah yeah that's what i mean
like it just seems to be this nice
little like because you know when you
push something so hard people feel like
all right well that's kind of a burden
like i feel like i have to do this yeah
but the vr seems like the icing on the
cake of this whole game yeah by the way
did you know yeah like and it's like you
know what it's actually really good so
that's a really that's some great icing
like top not enticing that's crazy it's
one of the it used to be one of the
flagship series of video games in
general it's got you know like movies an
entire like franchise built around it
now kind of weaned off with five and six
and recent titles but
uh the fact that i would actually
recommend playing
this iconic sequel in vr over just
standard on standard tv that's pretty
huge and it's yeah it's a first and it
it still it looks obviously it looks not
as good as like an ac tv would but it
there
it's
it looks good though
having headphones there were scares like
we did the section for that vr reaction
video
and there's a part with like this piano
i don't spoil too much but you kind of
saw some of the gameplay that part i
played again right after i was not
scared well i knew it was coming but
like even before the jump scares the
tone that you get with the headphones on
and just
again i don't want to like sound like
i'm just saying these really trite
things about vr that have already been
said millions of times but it really
like
rather than guiding a character up these
stairs to this old attic where i know
something bad's gonna happen
i am walking up
in this
creepy house to the second floor where i
know something bad is gonna happen and
just that the less uh there's less
removal than there is when i played the
next day when it occupies your entire
field of vision when you're wearing
headphones can't hear anything else all
of your senses
all of that input is coming directly
from the game there is nothing else to
pull you out of it right like you're not
seeing the edges outside of your tv
you're not hearing you know horn car
horns honking on the street outside like
you are
only receiving input from the game and
it's hard not to be more horrified when
you are just that much more immersed in
it i mean horror is really a perfect
choice for vr because vr is all about
immersion right so it is uh kind of a
perfect fit in a lot of ways which is
which is another reason to applaud
capcom for doing such a good job in
their execution because they really had
an amazing opportunity and they seized
it like they didn't let it you know just
kind of half-ass it or try to cram it
down people's throats they're just like
okay we're gonna do it right we're gonna
make it an option and we're gonna let
people experience it if they want it and
you know what it's really good i will
say the flip side to the coin that i was
gonna mention just in terms of content i
feel like there are certain sections of
the game where there's no point in
wearing a headset yeah like you are kind
of just walking around trying to collect
stuff and vr doesn't enhance anything at
all and there are moments that i feel
like we're explicitly designed for vr
where like an enemy will get right in
your face in a scripted moment or things
like that where it's like okay you did
this for vr but it's not
like it never took me out of the
experience like when when those moments
came i wasn't like oh just
just pandering nonsense but
um the phone part was weird like looking
over yeah on your disembodied hand like
hanging in the air it's kind of weird so
i can't imagine playing the entire game
in vr but certain sections will be
amazing so i that's that's sort of my
take on vr i love the fact that you can
actually hear something behind you and
turn your head to look yeah yeah sorry i
actually play a lot of it turn your head
to look sorry i just looked away from
the mic i found that playing standing up
and be able to actually like fully turn
to the sides was was a really cool way
to do it as opposed to like being seated
goob do i do that often make do segways
to bad 90s movies what bedazzled was the
one and it wasn't a bad segway it was
perfect
watch dogs 2 is it was watchdogs too but
with brendan frazier i like how nick
thinks a really good comeback is calling
you off topic mikey he hasn't compared
to me
yes like that hurt nick
off topic i'll leave to the insults to
nick margarita um
continue goo please uh but yes
so you do you have any intention of
playing a lot of the game in vr you do
yeah it's uh
i would recommend playing this game vr
over standard
it's it's fantastic i really like it and
i want to do a full play through my next
play through i want to do the mad house
difficulty in vr so mad house enemies
are faster uh in different spots and
also just more powerful and more happy
more health and there's they wear bras
they have braziers on they wear
pantaloons too
very weird aesthetics scary pantenes
though like horror themed pandolans yes
it's a mad house um and also like items
are more or sparser and uh yeah sparser
and uh you have limited scissors or i
think you can uh no no you carry around
cassette tapes like engravings yeah
which is awesome i i'm gonna play mad
house in vr
and you also but if you be so you have
to beat the game to unlock them
difficulty yeah kelly plaggy is she
newest associate editor is working on
like a kind of not a guy but just like a
roundup of what you get when you beat
the game so
we're also making it spoiler free so go
check that out we've been doing a lot of
resident stuff this week i'm trying to
plug as much as possible hopefully i'm
not forgetting anything um so my big
question though for for like related to
vr and resident evil is do you guys
think that this is going to encourage
other developers to invest these kind of
resources into vr in their own games i
mean is this like the start of something
bigger or is it going to end up being
kind of a one-off like oh resident evil
did it and that was kind of it
uh well so i think it's it's interesting
if you look at like what square enix is
trying to do with final fantasy 15 with
that thing that hasn't even come out yet
that looked just ridiculous i played it
i played 83 it was bad yeah like maybe
it's gotten better since like seven
months ago but it was bad right so
that might dissuade certain people but i
feel like resident evil is big enough
and the vr according to you guys is so
good that it has to sort of have an
effect on on outsiders it has to inspire
them to say
not everything is going to be final
fantasy 15 and vr right resident evil is
an example of how
yes it can work but we can also take a
risk on something as long as we don't
like risk the reputation of the series
on that like it has to coexist i think
with the traditional experience
certainly at the beginning
yes at the beginning yeah i think but
forever though you're going to see
people who don't want to do vr sure yeah
i mean i love vr but i still
don't opt to use it if i don't have to
you know it's rare that a game comes
along like thumper or maybe resident
evil 7 where i'm like no this is the
only way to play the game sure that you
know that you should play the game um
but i i think people have to recognize
outside that yeah this is proof of
concept it certainly seems like it uh so
last weekend just one more question
before i move on to the next section um
jeremy zahl he told me how to pronounce
his name sick uh he was asking me on
twitter
we kind of touched on this but i do want
to now that we're talking about vr
were you legitimately scared in resident
evil 7 or was it more like
uh survival horror scared i mean aside
from jump scares this game's scary to
you because nick margarita and like mary
and jake and myself were scared at a few
parts and i i'm pretty well versed in
horror there are a few parts especially
in vr that really scare me but jeremy
was asking what was your experience with
that
uh i will say that this is not the
scariest game i've ever played okay
however it is at points
certainly horrifying um i think this
game relies more on atmosphere and
tension than on explicit scares right
and i jump scares and other you know
types of scares i mean they come in a
lot of flavors but really it is a game
about tension more than anything and
sort of instilling dread in you and
making you feel like you're in this you
know inescapable situation and it's just
so oppressive and like you just can't
wait to get get out and like get this
weight off your chest and that's more
what it's about like it's more about
dread and panic that the atmosphere
induces than it is about ha ha you're
terrified you're going to scream out
loud like it's
i don't know it's a subtler it's a
subtler scary to me yeah so what you're
describing what i've felt is what i felt
the first time i played resident evil as
a
11 year old yeah you know 1998.
already had a beer at 11. you wouldn't
believe it
my beard's always been the same length
as my body is growing
it's like ears and nose when you're
older no those never stop growing
opposite sorry continue go on continue
um so
how would you compare this to say your
first experience playing the original
resident evil does it feel like that
same kind of dread intention because
that's what i'm getting i think
yes and no i mean i i would say that
fundamentally the emotions that you
experience are extremely similar but i
also think the game elicits them in a
slightly different way um i talked a
little bit in the review about how i
feel resident evil 7 draws from more
modern horror games i mean the first
person shift is easily the best example
of that you know turn towards modern
games played out last people played
alien isolation people had amnesia
i feel like it
creates tension and dread in a similar
way to those games
and
it does feel like a resident evil game
to me for a lot of reasons and that is
partially one of them but i also feel
like it is
more in line with our modern
expectations of what a horror game can
do so in my mind this is absolutely
resident evil game it fits within that
universe nicely it evokes a lot of the
same feelings that the early games did
but it also
comes from a newer place as well sure so
i think your mileage may vary i think
it's going to depend on the player and
and kind of what you get out of it
that's a really empty thing to say
because of course it will depend but um
to me it's a resident evil game for sure
and and the dread that you feel is
similar to the dread that those early
games evoked cool so uh yeah there you
have it i recommend playing that game in
vr
if possible if you have a psvr uh it's
it's awesome it's fantastic i really
enjoyed it we have john lucci putting up
a more in-depth thing about his vr
playthrough we also have the vr
reactions that a bunch of gamespot staff
kind of
were brave enough to try out uh you can
watch nick margarita
get scared a lot because he's kind of a
child uh yes anyway leonard adorable
lovable child
moving on to our last segment and it's
also about resident evil uh we were
thinking about doing this and then luigi
wagner on twitter
he asked a good question is resident
evil 7 a good place to start for
newcomers to the series
um
i will start answering that i think it
is uh i think you know this is where it
gets tough to not spoil things
whether it fits in
the traditional resident evil storyline
we can kind of talk about that in
general terms but
this game is such a different experience
than any other resident evils in some
ways in a lot of ways it's very much you
know a return to form we keep saying
right the survival the items the uh the
fact that it's very like kind of a
consolidated setting uh that you're
gonna learn from playing
spending more time in it it's also more
like atmospheric and tone and like
dreadful like you were saying but i
think this is
removed from the storyline of the
franchise enough that you could come
into this and have it might not make you
like appreciate the story of the earlier
games because it's nowhere near as
just convoluted and weird and
melodramatic which i love about the
older games but i think resident evil 7
is a great starting point it's a good
way to
it's weird because if you play this and
then go back to the other games it's
gonna feel like two separate
series except for like a few easter eggs
um but of course like if you know the
series well you're gonna see like
certain uh design tropes that have made
their way over in a good way um i don't
know scott what do you think could you
would you recommend someone that's never
played residential game i'm gonna answer
this in a really like diplomatic
non-answer kind of way come on so here's
here's my response diplomatic
here we go here's here it is here it is
i don't think
that you need to have played older
resident evil games in order to enjoy
resident evil 7.
right so if you have never played
resident evil
you can play resident evil 7 and you
will enjoy it basically as much as
somebody who has played resident evil
okay that's my response okay because i
don't want to spoil story stuff right
yeah um peter about an hour and a half
in
so so what would you have for breakfast
cheerios banana and two percent milk oh
very specific yeah um well what's going
on wait in one bowl yeah i'll slice up
the bananas i put on the cheers and i
pour some milk what else do you would
you what are you having for lunch i
don't know tussles nick's hair as he
walks out the door
because his bat
have a good day i was thinking like more
like his kids call back to the kid
but pet works too i'll be back later hon
i have to feed the swamp goblin and
change his litter
he's tracking he's just gardens litter
boxes i'm learning so much today it's a
weird anthropological journey because
he's rolling in his chairs you have to
add water and mud to the
damn good answer peter rob handler
really liked you
off the cuff your breakfast remark
we should probably let you actually
answer the question
no um i think what you said makes a
pretty good point like the fact this
game really does not try to like make a
huge deal about being part of the
resident evil universe
means that you don't really need to have
those
connections to the past and the sort of
modern horror as you were describing the
last segment also makes sense so it's it
really is a fresh start like it feels
like something
that is both resident evil but it
doesn't need to be resident evil yeah i
i think a lot of people that have played
uh more recent horror games which uh at
least first person aside from alien
isolation uh
have been on the indie scene right it's
uh amnesia there's more so yeah yeah and
i think i think obviously like again to
plug it one more time in our reviving
resident evil series we have an entire
episode the first episode is about how
the decline of resident evil and silent
hill the flagship horror series led to
this uh increase in horror from indie
developers who could take more creative
chances because they didn't have the the
risk involved the overhead and the
actual like aaa money like budgets
involved but i
also really like that i think resident
evil 7 takes what made those indie games
good and i'm just using india as a broad
term they're not all indie games so you
have like outlast two coming up red
barrel is very that's an indie developer
if i'm not mistaken i mean they're
technically independent in that they are
not owned by a larger parent company
that term gets indeed just like throwing
something but i think
not aaa uh i think resident evil 7 takes
what made those non-triple-a horror
games great and also combines it with
what made resident evil originally great
in a way that i think this is the best
introduction to the resident evil series
i think if someone has not played
resident evil up till this point
as much as remake and resident evil 2
are two of my favorite games in any
genre i don't think i would recommend
those first i think you'll have a deeper
appreciation of those if you can see how
it works in the modern day first
seven might also set you up to not like
those games though because they are
restrictive they're receptive and
you know like you were saying it's
pretty campy it's pretty yeah it
requires a lot of like esoteric like
knowledge of characters and events and
if you're playing remake that's when
they were introduced
what was the characters
uh no i know but i'm saying it by and
large though it's the camera it's the
campiness that will make people be like
this is right you were almost a chill
sandwich
the i think it will at least
show you that these kind of things can
work
oh yeah did you see it did you hear
um
we
tim turrey and i from capcom played
resident evil yesterday on a live stream
and he was using your account because
you had the saves yeah that we wanted to
start from and he kept getting a bunch
of bronze trophies so i'm like you're
racking up the bronze trophies for uh
peter brown so tim's like oh peter
bronze
so we were talking about that last night
that is pretty good pete bronze reviews
editor at gamespot i need a tan if i'm
gonna live up to that moniker pete
bronze more like pete
saran wrap pete self tanner
pete self tanner brown i am transparent
we have a very pasty crew on the lobby
thankfully this table is white so
hopefully the contrast makes us look
less pale it makes paris or it reflects
up at us and makes me look even milkier
it's definitely possible milky is a
disgusting way to spread someone's skin
don't moist and milky when we break this
video i'm deleting that
please do milky stubble at least it's
not like you look very marshmallowy
today
people you kind of do i always do
pete bronze
um mike's getting nancy so i think if
this would i personally think this would
be a good introduction to the series i
don't know if you're gonna like love
remake going back to it but i think
it'll show you how
those kind of design tenets can work in
a modern day horror game i think in that
cancer interview
you combined our diplomats yeah yes
that's my job here
um yeah so uh luigi wagner thank you for
the question uh we were considering
doing a segment on that and uh
yeah we're glad you uh tweeted in at me
uh so that's the end i'm gonna plug a
few more things before we end off the
residential segment uh again reviving
resident evil the two-part series that
some more hussein worked on go watch the
behind the scenes documentary it's very
good um
scott's review was up on gamespot eight
out of ten he really liked the game a
lot of outlets did i do pete's liking it
so far um we have guides going up on
antique coins the bobble heads the
new game plus items we have a lot of
that stuff going up we have vr which we
just talked about if you're just joining
the show or if you're watching this on
youtube or gamespot has a broken out
video uh play this game in vr
it's a great game it's for all intents
and purposes it feels like uh capcom
is back with resident evil and let's
hope they continue this uh they've kind
of hinted that this is gonna be another
you know that the structure of they do
three games like this three games like
this three games like this not counting
spin-offs so let's hope like you know
theoretically a resident evil eight and
nine kind of can build on the success
that this inevitably will carry over uh
in the post
launch weeks uh so thank you for joining
for resident evil we're not done with
the show yet but uh if you have any more
questions about resident evil you
tweeted us scott butterworth peter brown
mike mccarty we uh we're pretty we're
all pretty you know like i know scott
pete are both active with twitter all
the time responding i mainly just rant
about politics though yeah
uh i just fave pics of retro games we'll
try to stop watching uh
nazi punching
videos to answer your tweets
oh yeah we could get into some stuff
it's been a weird week guys
right now but yes thank you so much for
joining us for resident evil uh leave
your questions in the comments i will
peruse them when i get the chance uh and
then i'll respond on twitter and mahari
thanks so much
wow cool there's a lot of resident evil
17 there's a lot of reason i have no
problem with that what is even left what
else
i don't know what i'm talking about what
is left to say let's pull the plug oh no
that's that was the last segment i'm
just saying like the show is not done
because i want to bring this up again
our old friend
give it no give the scott this camera
yeah do it uh again
so uh shiva who managed our twitter
account has as of now i checked earlier
at the beginning of the show has tweeted
about the giveaway you can get a turtle
beach pc headset uh recon 320. uh we're
gonna announce the winner on thursday so
reply to the tweet if you want to be
considered
uh and we will look through those shiva
will uh we'll pick someone at random i'm
actually not sure how it's based on
grammar it's based on grammar yeah so if
you respond eloquently to the tweet the
most words with the best grammar is that
that cross section yeah yes yes most
words with the best grammar yeah
so like the more you write the more
chances you have to screw something up
so if you can write more than anyone
else ella couldn't he lee he replied
with the nessen
subject of
tyranny in this here dire hour of the
united states with
the dictatorial
pressure being put on these peoples here
i'm gonna give me that 81 characters
give me that heads every letter give me
that headset
i can't take that set huge conflict of
veneers i'm not going to do it
that's true we cannot win the headset
that we are giving away no
that would be
dishonest
i'm a very honest person
peter you look like such a liar right
now that is not something an honest
person says this weird little smart
people don't say i am a smart person
honest people don't say i'm an honest
person no i don't i don't feel the need
to say i'm honest because i am honest
cool this is i'm glad we finished off
those segments before things went off
the rails like they inevitably do so
yeah
why do we even have rails second
this is no train this isn't a train this
is a we're on a dune buggy going over
the deserts of video games and
peter bronze wait jean luke i think i
got one more thing that i have jean-luc
uh i have queued up and ready to roll
scott have you played a link between
worlds
uh not a while i don't know where this
is going uh well take a look at our tv
if jean-luc has it cued up oh look at
pete on the wall
yeah loop that [ __ ]
[Music]
keep yeah wait no john luke rewind that
go again i want more so good yeah if you
have not played link between worlds
here's your uh here's your subliminal
preview here's your exclusive uh post
mortem on link between worlds one more
time please one more time do it
this is pete sidling along a wall in two
dimensions
will literally just be this it will be
an hour of this yes everybody in the
chat save this make me gifts if vine was
still around that would you that could
bring vine back i shouldn't amuse myself
so much but i like that vines are all
archived but you could bring vine back
over the star the evan spiegel from
snapchat should see that and in the same
way that justin timberlake brought sexy
back yeah
you brought sexy back with that i'm
gonna work on my video game and like
character impressions yeah all right uh
holy [ __ ] thank you so much for joining
everyone we will be back next week to
talk more video games and video game
news whatever happens with the next week
on wednesday at 11 00 p.m
a.m 11 a.m not 11 p.m that would be
irresponsible and stupid
11 a.m pacific that's where the p came
out i thought it was peter and mike
peter bronze peter and mike will be here
uh who knows what we're gonna be talking
about but again send in your suggestions
like luigi did for segments and we can
talk about them or just send in comments
make fun of pete for that dance uh make
fun of scott for being so diplomatic all
the time don't make fun of me please
make fun of nick margarita make fun of
nick margarita
which is basically just talking about
nick margaret coming into this chat here
to defend himself goob needs
reinforcements to make fun of nick
margarita anyway thank you so much for
joining us go play resident evil yakuza
tales bursaria if that's your thing uh
resident 7 and vr go check out all our
resident evil content watch reviving
resident evil tomorrow hussein did a
great job adam mason did an awesome job
on it i loved helping them do it
we'll see you next week
[Music]
there